all right Jim your Quarterly's look very
good how are things going at the library
oh I told you I couldn't close it so so
you've come to the master for guidance
is this what you're saying grasshopper
actually you called me in here yeah all
right well let me show you how it's done
yes I'd like to speak to your office
manager please yes hello this is Michael
Scott I am the regional manager of
Dunder Mifflin paper products I just
wanted to talk to you manager aisle
manager all right done deal thank you
very much sir you're a gentleman and a
scholar
well I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
my mistake mmm that was a woman I was
talking to need a very low voice
probably a smoker so that's the way it's
done I've I've been at Dunder Mifflin
for 12 years the last four as regional
manager when I come through here see we
have the entire floor so this is my
kingdom far as the eye can see ah this
is our receptionist pam pam beesley pam
has been with us for forever right Pam
well if you think she's cute now you
should have seen her a couple of years
ago all right what uh any messages um
yeah just a fax oh yeah this is from
corporate how many times have I told you
that there's a special filing cabinet
for things from corporate all the waste
paper basket oh look at that faith
people say I am the best boss
they go god we've never worked in a
place like this before you're hilarious
and you get the best out of us
I think that pretty much sums it up I
found it at Spencer Gifts
you